[Music]
foreign
welcome back
so I couldn't help myself I have to do
another phase portrait this one is one
of my absolute favorite uh kind of
dynamical systems to play around with is
the particle in this uh cortic or fourth
order potential well given by this
formula here my potential function is a
fourth order polynomial minus a second
order polynomial and again by Newton's
Second Law we can write down that the
Dynamics X double dot are minus the
gradient of this potential so that
should be a positive X
minus an X cubed so x minus X cubed
and I'm just going to put in a kind of
almost like air quotes here this
optional you know minus uh
this is like an optional
optional friction or damping okay and so
I'm actually going to draw the phase
portrait with and without friction so
you know at first we're going to ignore
this friction sorry this x dot this
damping or friction I'm going to draw
the face portrait and then I'm going to
draw it again
um with the friction so I'm actually
going to put my axes up here because I
think I need uh maybe I'll just put
okay good
good
yes
okay and I'm gonna draw my face portrait
X V and X V
kind of uh
without
friction
and then I'm going to do it again with
friction so this is uh with
friction
and these are going to make some super
cool pictures these are absolutely
beautiful we've actually made t-shirts
my wife and I have made t-shirts of the
face portrait of this dynamical system
that's how cool it is okay good
um and like I do uh we're going to turn
this into a system of coupled first
order equations instead of a second
order equation
so we're going to introduce
um
x dot equals V I probably shouldn't do
pink here it doesn't really matter I'm
not going to do pink here I'm going to
do blue to stay consistent
so x dot equals V and V Dot equals x
minus X cubed and again there will be
this optional you know minus V term that
we're going to add and it's probably not
minus V I might make this minus 0.01 x
dot or minus 0.01 V just so you can draw
your pictures a little bit more sensibly
if you actually want to do this at home
okay
[Music]
um
and so what we do is we find our fixed
points we find the Jacobian the
linearization of these non-linear
Dynamics at those fixed points and that
tells me locally what the Dynamics are
going to look like
so again from first principles physics I
know that I'm going to have a fixed
point at the top of this hill if I put
my particle or my bead okay we're
talking about a little particle that's
rolling around on this potential surface
or a little bead that's kind of sliding
along this wire surface here and so if I
started at this point here I would stay
there forever it's a fixed point now if
I pushed it if I nudged it it's going to
roll off but if I was perfectly balanced
that's a fixed Point that's a fixed
point and that's a fixed point so I'm
going to just draw these down because we
know already that they're going to look
like this
probably shouldn't have gone all the way
down here but that's life
okay and I'm just going to write down
what my fixed points are
semi-fixed
points of course V is going to have to
equal zero for this to be a fixed point
so V is always going to have to equal
zero and I know I have three fixed
points I'm just going to write them out
um
in all of these cases V has to equal
zero and if V equals zero then x minus X
cubed has to equal zero so the easiest
way for that to happen is for X to equal
zero that's definitely a fixed point
this is the x equals zero fixed point
right here
so x equals 0 V equals 0 is a fixed
point
but if x equals plus or minus 1 this
also equals zero so plus one and minus
one plus one and minus 1 are also fixed
points this is you know plus one this is
minus one those are also fixed points of
X with velocity equal to zero so those
are our three fixed points
we compute our Jacobian matrix DF DX
this is my Vector field you know f of x
and V so DF with respect to
um that Vector I call this uh I'm
calling this little x v stacked Vector X
under bar
so the derivative of f with respect to X
is this Jacobian matrix
partial of the first equation with
respect to X is zero partial of the
first equation with respect to V is one
partial of the second equation with
respect to X is
1 minus three x squared and partial of
the second equation with respect to V is
minus 1 if I have friction zero if I
don't okay it would be zero if I don't
have friction it would be minus one if I
do have friction or minus 0.01 or 0.001
whatever I say the magnitude of this
friction term is is going to be what's
down here I shouldn't have smudged that
should not have smudged that
okay
and now
the last thing this is okay not so bad I
found my fixed points I computed the
Jacobian now I have to evaluate this
Jacobian at each of these fixed points
and find the eigenvalues and
eigenvectors okay so I'm just going to
uh to write this down this is pretty
simple so at the zero zero point dfdx
at
um
my zero zero point is going to be
0 1 1 and again optionally if I have
friction a negative one here if not
it'll be zero and in either case we're
going to get saddle Dynamics
for this point this point is going to be
a saddle okay which totally makes sense
because it's unstable if I nudge the
system it's going to go unstable
uh and you could compute it to
eigenvectors and eigenvalues you know
you could do that and the eigenvectors
are going to be pointing in the 45
degree Direction with these ones
unstable and these ones stable I'm
skipping some steps you could you know
do this in python or Matlab or by hand
to find these eigenvectors
and so these eigenvectors are pointing
in this direction here
I know for these mechanical F equals ma
systems usually my Saddles are in this
45 degree orientation
and then both of the other points
actually have exactly the same
linearization Jacobian because x squared
whether I plug in plus one or minus one
this x squared is the same
so dfdx
at either plus or minus 1 0 either of
those points is going to equal 0 1
and now one minus 3 is minus two
and then again this optional
um you know friction could be here or
not and I really should have called this
like you know 0.01 x dot .01 V minus
0.01 minus 0.01 minus 0.01 I'm just lazy
but when you actually compute this use a
small number here so it doesn't botch
your eigenvalues too much
and I'm going to claim that this
with no damping so with um
with no damping this is going to have
plus or minus
um you know some constant
eye you know some number times I so this
is going to be a center
a stable Center
or with friction it's going to be a
spiral
sink with friction
meaning I'm going to have like a minus a
plus or minus I for my eigenvalues I'm
going to have a negative real part plus
or minus I uh complex conjugate part
with with damping with friction
and so now I'm actually ready to draw
these phase portraits so I'm going to
start with the no friction case because
that'll be a lot easier the without
friction case where this fixed Point
these two fixed points are just pure
centers there's no friction so they just
you know a little particle is going to
oscillate forever in these Wells
and so in that case these are going to
be concentric little circles
and I'm pretty sure that the direction
of the arrows go here if I remember from
my last lecture they go like this
similarly
um concentric circles here
um like that
meaning that if I start with a little
particle that's a teeny bit up this well
it's just going to oscillate back and
forth forever that's what this XV
diagram having a circle means is that
you know X is decreasing while V
increases then X in you know
if I start here at
um
zero velocity
then X is going to move in the right
direction X is going to move in this
right direction and velocity is going to
pick up
velocity is going to hit its maximum
value here at the fixed Point version of
and where X is at the fixed point and
then it's going to overshoot X is going
to increase until V eventually is zero
at the top of this and then it's going
to turn around and do the same thing
okay so these totally make sense
and down here the only thing that's
going to change is that now these
centers are no longer perfect circles
they are going to kind of
how do I want to draw this they're going
to you know spiral inward like that and
these guys are going to
um
I don't want to draw it these guys are
also going to spiral inward like that
that's the only thing that's going to
change
but now again this is all that I can say
from the local linearization from just
taking these jacobians and evaluating
locally we're zooming in near these
fixed points where these non-linear
Dynamics look linear and this is what
the local linearization looks like
the global structure because of the
physics of the system
and usually I start with the saddle
point and I think to myself what happens
if I nudge this thing a teeny bit to the
right so it's basically going to roll
down this hill it's going to go up to
the same height
here I'm just going to draw myself a
line so I don't mess up like last time
same thing if I did here if I nudged a
teeny bit to the left it's going to roll
up this hill to the same height
and what that means is that this
trajectory is going to kind of go until
X is at this point here where I have
zero velocity because I've come to the
same potential energy then it's going to
turn around and go right back the way it
came perfectly symmetrically
back like this
and this is called the unstable manifold
of this fixed point because this is the
unstable Direction This is and it's
curved so it's a manifold and it
attaches to the stable manifold it'll
kind of come back and there's a perfect
trajectory with a perfect position and
velocity that will roll right up exactly
to that fixed Point that's this blue
curve here similarly if I nudge it to
the left I get the same thing in Reverse
like that
and the last piece I want to draw is
what if I had my point here but I pushed
it with a bigger velocity I gave it like
a big initial kick so I start at this x
location but at a big positive uh big
positive velocity then what I'm going to
do is I'm going to overshoot to a
farther point
so I'm going to overshoot to a farther
point
I'm going to turn around and I'm going
to pass right through my fixed point
with a negative velocity I'm going to
turn around and pass right through my
fixed point with a negative velocity and
then I'm going to overshoot to another
point on the left
and then I'm going to repeat that
forever and ever and ever so this is
another
orbit where if I have a little bit more
energy than this fixed point I'm just
going to go around and around forever
and ever
picture for this double well potential
for this double potential well
and when I add friction the only thing
that changes is that these stop being
perfect centers and they spiral in the
kind of symmetry breaks and now they
spiral in and now I believe that this if
I nudge my system from this perfect
fixed point it will roll up to a little
bit less High then it'll roll to a
little bit less high and eventually
it'll get trapped in this well and
similarly if I kick it to the left it'll
eventually get trapped in this left well
so if I kick it to the right
I am going to eventually kind of get
sucked into this well if I kick it from
the left I'm eventually going to get
sucked into this well
and I get this kind of cool spiral
pattern here
and then you can continue these out
just by Logic it has to be like this
which I really like uh drawing this kind
of candy cane stripe
um
pattern here and so this actually
segments phase space the x v space every
single point every single point I start
with eventually after friction after
enough time after it oscillates enough
will either land and die in one of this
these well or the other either this well
or this well and so you can almost kind
of reverse back and figure out what you
know all of the points that ended up in
this well I'm just going to draw them in
pink all of the points that ended up in
this well
here
form this stripe
of the system let's try not to mess this
up this stripe here all of these points
will eventually end up in this left well
that I've drawn in pink
and all of these
points that I'm going to draw in blue
I'm going to just emanate outward from
this blue point all of these points are
going to end up in the red well in the
right well the right well not the red
wall
does that make sense So eventually there
is this whole kind of interesting candy
stripe landscape of points that will
eventually go to either the left well or
the right well so these are kind of
called attracting basins these two
basins of Attraction and all
trajectories are eventually going to end
up at these two fixed points very very
cool this is the one we made a t-shirt
of my wife made a really cool Photoshop
of
um
the scream face so let's see if I can do
this without botching it too terribly
yeah the scream face uh
in the middle of face space so no one
can hear you scream
in Phase space
all right so that's phase portraits uh
this is one of my favorite dynamical
systems and you can do a lot of powerful
stuff even for very non-linear systems
by finding the fixed points linearizing
around the fixed points looking at the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors and you
know using your intuition and geometry
all right thank you
[Music]
foreign